You wanted a fero-kusou gaki, I gave you a ferrokusou dente.
You wanted a doten hag, I gave you a doten hag.
You wanted a dorky yandere, I gave you a dorky yandere!
You wanted a masochistic brocon, I gave you a masochistic drozon.
You wanted a mild dominatrix, I gave you a mild dominatrix.
And now I bring you the VTuber that no one asked for, a goddamn hypnotic cuttlefish.
Did I kick or did I f***ing kick, ladies and gentlemen?
I hope you enjoyed your evening so far.
Let me formally introduce myself.
Ladies and gentlemen, I'm Strony Cuttle.
The surname is because I'm a cuttlefish.
And Strony because I am the daughter of the gamer Strontium, my dad's gamer tag.
And I wouldn't be here without him, you know, because he came from his b***h sack.
Anyway, age, age, ladies and gentlemen.
Oh, yet again, I have failed the VTuber challenge of tell us your age.
Cuttlefish normally live to a year, so time's ticking.
Anyway, my birthday is October 10th, which is actually National Sweden Cuttlefish Day.
They're both step-for-the-pod, so I don't mind sharing that birthday.
My height is 162 centimetres, which makes me 5'3", because I forgot to update this hi-ho over here now.
For my languages, turns out, if you're born in Scotland,
the British government recognises Scottish slang as its own language,
so in your face, I can speak two languages.
Grace, I am a cuttlefish, and I'm also good at the 100-metre sprint.
Thank you, thank you, I'll be here all week.
My likes and dislikes.
ASMR, if you like ASMR, you're going to get spoiled, rotten on my channel.
Or any of the VLOR girls' channels.
Shows your plasters.
Oh God, can you see it? Wait, you're not supposed to see that part!
I like seeing victory on my screen because I could use any tiddly wink of serotonin.
And I also like plasters and band-aids.
I wonder why.
For no nefarious reason.
For my dislikes.
I don't like bullies in video games.
Your teammates aren't all going to magically be MLG pros, so relax.
I don't like serious people, I don't like seriousness.
I think my gen mates can all pray for a bunch of bouts.
I can't be serious, it's terrible.
I'm the most unprofessional person they've probably ever worked with in their entire life.
My hi-ho.
And I don't like mongolian throat singing, I'm so sorry.
People seem to really like it, but I don't.
It doesn't sound nice.
Apologize to the one mongolian throat singer that's watching right now.
Huggy, I'm nice and generic.
Sorry, there's nothing interesting about my taste.
Movies, Lord of the Rings.
Definitely come.
Animes, nice and generic again.
Books, I actually started reading books this year.
I know this sounds crazy as a sentence because people read books in general.
Me, however, I started this year.
I really like dystopian books that talk about human nature and how humans are stinky poo poo heads.
For my music, Hatsunomiku and Atarashigako, I want to see them live if it's possible.
Oh, yeah, just a wee bit of a gamer.
It doesn't mean I'm good at games.
Now before there's that one person that's like,
eh, you've played all these games, that means you're an MLG pro.
No, relax, relax.
I've played games full stop.
Okay, these are the games that I remember playing or just kind of like have a good,
yeah, play them type thing, okay.
See who's been an Xbox gamer to apologize for my goals.
I want to get monetized on YouTube, so feel free to subscribe
because we have been called like crazy since then.
I want to stream so much that you can basically read everything in my voice.
You know, you'll be Scots yourself and you can apply for citizenship and all that good stuff.
I also want to create a Mega A Smart collab with my gen mates,
which I've already got quite a few on the way.
So don't worry, it's coming.
You just got to wait.
I have a childhood dream actually of 100,000 gamer score
and it's actually possible now with Xbox Game Pass.
I would absolutely love to explore a heken amount of childhood games
and I would love to play like your childhood games as well.
There's a little fun factoid about me.
I'm a wee bit of a workaholic.
So I would like to say that for every 1,000 subscribers I get on my YouTube channel,
I'm going to upload a celebratory.
Really hard to say that if you're Scottish.
ASMR video pair 1,000 subscribers.
I've already got like tons ready to go, so don't be shy.
You know what to do, wink, wink.
I also want to challenge myself.
I want to collab.
I want to make ASMR collabs with over 100 different v-tubers
and I'm actually so much of a workaholic.
I already have three confirmed with v-tubers outside of VLR, so I'm very serious about that.
If you ever have a 3DO, you're a v-tuber, I'm coming to find you in your DMs.
I would love if we could read Lord of the Rings together.
I think it would be so fun.
I'm not a very strong reader, but I think it would be really cute to do like a little
before the end of stream, read one chapter or something like that.
And last but certainly not least, I would love to get stream sniped.
I absolutely adore it.
I love playing multiplayer games where you can join me.
You can have an amazing time and have so much fun.
It's just one of my favorite things, okay?
So please do not be shy.
These are my goals.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I'm dumb.
Okay, I'm really dumb.
I don't know how to come up with tags.
I'm not funny.
I'm not good with puns.
So I am more than happy to take any suggestions.
My ushi marks are squid, but I'm a cuttlefish.
And then the second emoji kind of looks like a man bowing.
Hmm?
Maybe that is a hint to what I might try to make content-wise.
And for fan names, there is only going to be one option.
Come on.
Let's not beat around the bush.
You are my refling.
You will always be my refling.
And thank you so much for waiting.
I have bloody missed you.
Special shout out to Nari and Squishy Goal.
You may have noticed a bit of a trending pattern.
Squishy Goal that conceptualized us all and now I helped out and made us come to life,
which is beautiful, beautiful.
So thank you everyone who came together to make this fantastic gen of indulge.
Oh, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Most people get to do, oh, this is my gen mate's impression.
Me.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I picked my gen mates.
Do you understand?
I picked them, okay?
Now I'm going to tell you why I picked them.
Mercy's determination.
She was going to make it no matter what.
The definition of mercy in the dictionary, if you look up, it just says determined, okay?
There was no way in heck she was not going to get in.
That's all I'm going to say on that one.
Emi.
Emi said to someone who's being rude to her to keep themselves safe and Minecraft
and then she instantly got the part, okay?
I say, I say, oh, I say has fantastic experience and history and she's such a hard worker.
She had the most professional application.
Even though English is in her first language and now I got them, I say you're impressive.
Then Azura.
Okay, I describe Azura as my little diamond in the rough.
Now hear me out before you're like, it's not an insult, relax.
I'm not told the full story yet.
I was going to cross off Azura's stream as I was reviewing her because she wasn't talking.
She wasn't interacting.
And then she said three words in that voice.
Azura.
She instantly became Azura.
She said three words and she got the damn part.
Sheebie.
Sheebie is everything.
I should have been in another life, okay?
I could not have asked for better gen mates.
I am blown away that these girls even have freaking applied to such a crazy idea.
And here we are, debut and you guys have shown nothing but love and support and we are all so thankful.
I'm sure I speak for all of us when we were like, holy fuck, thank you.
Right, let me take you to Zabbit.
I forgot to pull it.
It's for decoration.
Okay, the tentacle in the back is for decoration.
Let me do the full body.
Let's start with the full body.
It may have a bandaid on for reasons.
But as you see, I got some swivelly hips.
Thank you, Nari.
So if you didn't know, I actually have what's known as a French manicure and pedicure.
Again.
Don't even be careful with my thighs because of the bandaid.
Is this smart?
Is this what?
Okay, okay.
I don't think that's smart.
As you can see, if you look really close to the elbows, I have pearlescent to my outfit.
My outfit isn't white, it's pearlescent.
So I shimmer as I move about.
It's fantastic.
And so does my seashells at the top too.
But yeah, I'm in the Yukata because it's a homage to Japanese culture because without Japanese culture, let's be honest.
Any VTubers would be here.
Okay, let me get real close.
Hopefully this isn't uncomfortable.
I know some people aren't like the best with eye contact.
If I open my eyes, it opens too.
Oh, and I'm sad.
I'm sad.
I have pupil restrict.
What did you say?
I'm on a muse.
You failed me.
These are my heart eyes.
I love them.
You ever seen a blushing cultfish before?
You know how cultfish have hypnotic patterns?
May I please do this for you?
Are you ready?
Hey.
We're going to be using this for a lot of ASMR.
I don't know.
But if you're really struggling, like if you're really struggling, how about this?
Yeah, it's over for you.
Just admit it, it's over for you.
I mean, how can you resist?
How can you resist this little Scottish accent?